I
so first it's got to be that kind of so
I can't go like this
you're gonna make this contact and we
can't go like this
that's too much this is too little but I
have to make contact like you got to
charge that initial content
[Music]
connection there we have it now okay and
now I can yield so I can't deal before
it it'll get pushed in charge then deal
okay charge sometime you'll fit you'll
see me bow into it if you pay attention
you go back and you watch the videos
I've got you I don't I don't do this
this you see this well I just have this
posture for posture sake right as he's
moving into me I'm moving into him and
sometimes I'm here it's very hard to
yield when you don't have that so first
charge and then around it can reach to
him charge you can expand from here
[Music]
okay and once you charge and you yield
try not to yield with your arm this is
why I yield with my body because if my
body is just get that initial charge
usually young and then so some things
which is related to you going young you
reversing when you go young here you you
don't have the right cutting angle to
effective center so if I take this Teddy
neck oh do you see it's going oh you see
that it's going like that and just as
you hold on to it doesn't change that
sometimes you're here like this but
you're just pushing back into this
energy right there do you see that do
you guys see that so we see a lot of
this one we see a lot of this one some
other ones let's see are you going like
this okay and the reason why that's
happening is
because you didn't neutralize the
contact point and you got stuck there so
you can't go around the harm
okay so when I go like this you you have
to let the arm fall into this place what
you're doing is you're trying to move
your cut
thanks differently let me let his arm go
into that you see how I'm doing that so
I'm gonna exaggerated I want his elbows
to go be here the arm goes into it and
not me coming back and trying together
okay so young and then the yield and his
arm will go into it right and given you
can feel this so young goat you charged
on y'all yen and then here you have your
young on the other side of a record
[Music]
so it doesn't change if you go big it's
still the same if you go too small you
still going around that do you
understand that so you're not getting
stuck on this side I'm on the other side
so I haven't even dropped my arm yet
okay so let's try that thinking
differently right so charge two things
differently I actually go young at first
then yeah not at first
I actually let him come underneath it
rather than me go over it right and then
the other thing is this elbow hinge when
I have my elbow down he can't come
underneath it okay it's my help was
always gonna be lower than yeah so just
like a door I want to walk through I'll
have to open the door and then as I'm
coming around charge yeah my elbow comes
up you see that my elbow comes up and
then this is the same body where you'll
always do so I'm here I relax the
shoulder
I keep an expanding Center and I drop
the shoulder blade okay so whoa right
and let that come up coming up allows me
to get over the top of his arm right
just keep it all locked down
[Music]
hey don't let this be down
let's look at this there right now this
is the same just look at it even though
you scrap it it doesn't really change
okay so I put a hat in here and I come
around and now he puts a hand on one you
see it's the same you see that okay so
that's the trickery of this technique is
it looks like it's gonna be the same but
the difference is that I'm going around
to energy can see that so when I go here
and he go this is the same technique hi
okay I show you I show you whatever say
he goes right and it he's he's strong
but so on he's not gonna get it either
right do you understand so you could see
well how do you guys are like going I'm
gonna muscle here do you understand but
anyway you muscle then I can muscle
[Music]
and if you go home why is that
look go ahead and go keep going keep
trying see now we're doing the same
thing we're doing the same thing so the
one who is stronger it's gonna win okay
but what this technique is doing and
instead of going here like that I'm
going around everything okay and we just
do that I don't know how you're going to
do it but you have contention points so
right right here you see how I'm lifting
so I'll go around it do you see how I'm
doing that and then right here right do
you feel that so I go around to begin do
you see that and then when I come back
like that you feel the knuckles I'm
gonna go around meet again do you see
that and now you feel that knife edge
there I'm gonna go around it again
do you see I'm doing that right and now
you feel the back of my hand all the
time you you feel that I'm gonna go
around it again you see that and then
you you never had anything to push them
okay so boom with the charge you see
it's in your palm right and then I'm
gonna disappear that and I can feel
that's upon me right so I'm going to not
keep working on that I'll go around it
and then I feel that right there right
you feel that and
not an impression therapist you be
strong be strong you see so I gotta go
around and again see I'm taking it off
like that
okay and then I climb over to this hop
and if I cut down here be strong you
think you're weak be strong okay now
watch I'm gonna lift my elbow and I went
up I went around it can see so the way
that you want to think of this technique
is it looks like two swords are engaging
but one of them's going around the other
one right and then it's in your throat
by the time you realize okay so if you
watch it's a totally different thing
than you're going like this you should
never feel it it's too late now when you
finally feel it so all of that all of
this part is neutralized neutralized
neutralized legs very much like a snake
is coiling around the sword okay so you
can go oh no do you see cycle realm see
and then the knuckles right there do you
feel that so you go around it right and
then I'll go around it again right to
make me okay so anywhere that you are
pushing on the guy where that makes you
feel stronger that's actually where they
would push back on you okay you want him
to push you wanted them to push on
nothing dig that's like you try to you
can already have the charge right
because he has an intention
and I read his intention so sometimes it
looks like we're going and I've yielded
you seen that but what but what I did
before was because I'm already hard
already charged do you understand that
so I'm not sitting here like this this
is not the same thing we're going a
party meeting and then you can use your
footwork to help reconcile whatever you
found difficult to reconcile in the
static see what it was the height will
you take how much you receive going
backwards all that kind of stuff and you
get to play with that so you should you
should not have it should be easier okay
well yeah you don't keep the foot where
you can just still could do it like that
this makes it easy let's try it know
when someone is reconciling my my energy
you're like oh it's on you see that you
have to take you Kimmy you have to go
where it's taking you to go what the
beginner tends to do is when they fall
into the alley park right then they fall
however they want and if he keeps going
I'm falling away from the law do you see
that is gonna hurt and usually because
we're all so nice here we let you up and
out of it but you're not improving okay
so in the same way that he goes around
your energy now it's my turn
he's seeing I reconciled that energy and
then I'm practicing the inside he's
practicing the young side not it
so at first I give the energy to
reconcile then he gives it and I have to
reconcile in here so watch this thing
where you go oh you're gonna get really
hurt or you're gonna force your noggin
is not training with you okay all right
let's go so again I'm coming in and I
have my push and now it's my turn
oh I can feel that I can feel how II so
what I do is relax accept and move to
get rid of it okay so that's your job
you're doing it as noggin and the
incentive is hey do what your teacher
says
if they do the form right let's puke it
the incentive is stop hurting okay but
it's the same skillset so you come in
and you don't want to go ah no no
we'll just we're gonna stop you here
okay and then my job is to move where
that stops hurting he's gonna stay there
like okay and I'm gonna go to where it
stops hurt he goes this is genuinely
where you start to feel it and he's
gonna stay there are strongly huh and
then I'm gonna move to get it to stop
hurting okay okay and then he stays
there and then I moved to get that to
stop her okay and I keep my full palm on
them okay all right try it as you can
time just reconciling that energy every
time over and over and over that's all
I'm doing
okay so I'm coming in Oh reconciling you
don't have one you can't meet because
you don't know what he's gonna do you
don't know what you're gonna do but you
always reconcile that energy so he you
should cut it in the air not cut it to
me hahaha hey it doesn't change how fast
I go he should always cut in the air
no charge
yeah but I have a center okay so he
reconciled my attack the art key betas
are to go around by energy right my arms
go around his energy his I'm going
around my energy and that gives me right
into his Center if I'm playing attention
and I mean I mean aiming towards his
Taunton and I can just project you'll
feel that are good yen on you you go gin
walnuts so you go into the center just
like everything so I'm here I tried to
trap his arm his arm goes yen and I will
go up to the center line and spinal are
saving here arm goes get going this s
I'm not pushing him like this
this energy transfers injured essential
[Music]